Kimi's is very simple but also very
effective unsupervised clustering
algorithm it tries to partition the data
set into K predefined clusters with each
data points belongs to only one group
cool let's goes to a simple two
dimensional example to have a better
understanding of this idea there are
three major steps is that one we
randomly chose K data points from the
data set as initial Center in this case
k is equal to three and we won't
discussed how do we choose K later okay
once we have these centers in step two
we can calculate the distance between
the data points to these centers then we
can assign h data points to the closest
centers in this example for point a we
compute its distance to c1 c2 and c3
respectively and after comparing the
lens of d1 d2 and d3 we figured out that
history is the smallest therefore we
assign a to c3
we then move to point B and follow the
same procedure qu we keep repeating this
process until all the data points are
assigned
then we carefully the centers new
position by taking the average of all
the points within the cluster keep
repeating this process until all the
centers stop moving now it's a coding
type we're going to show you how to
train and visualize k-means algorithm in
jupiter notebook let's first introduce
all necessary libraries here we are
using the umpire for data manipulation
make blobs from a scale and data set for
data preparation k means from a scaling
cluster from all training and matplotlib
and Seabourn for each addition KU so the
first step is to create and the load the
data set big blobs for masc dataset will
help us to generate some Gaussian blobs
for clustering now let's go through the
parameters of this function then some
point is the total number of points
equally divided among the clusters in
this dataset and feature is the number
of features for each samples in this
case we have n features as to which
means the dataset is in two dimension we
set centers equal to 3 which means there
are three cluster generativity in this
data set cluster STD it's a standard
deviation of each course in cluster the
random stage parameter is just the
random state for the data preparation we
can reproduce the data generation
process we sustain random States setting
great now let's have a look at the
generated x and y access 200 samples in
8 there are two columns in the data set
each columns represent a feature for
that sample why it's just the list of
clusters labels for each sample as
expected both of them has 200 samples in
them
now let's try to visualize the data set
in the pot here we are using scatter
function from madpal leap to visualize
the data set in two dimension if you
have more than two features you can use
some dimension reduction techniques like
PCA to reduce the features into two
dimension and then visualize it in a two
dimensional space from the plot you may
find that there are a lot of overlapping
between different clusters and there are
no clear boundary between them the
reason for that is that we have pets the
Gaussian standard deviation has one
which is a relatively large standard
deviation here I encourage you to
experiment with the standard deviation
parameter offline trying to reduce it to
a smaller value and you will find a
clear boundary between different
clusters cool let's move - how to train
a kemi's model with this dataset here we
are using camis class in s : a zero
let's have a closer look at the
parameters in this class first we have n
clusters set as 3 and cluster is the
number of clusters to form as well at
the number of centers to generate this
is one of the most important
hyperparameters for this model and we
will tell you how to choose this number
zone in each defines the method for
initialization here we set it as a
random in this case we choose 3
observation at random from the data set
for the initial centers n 8 is the
number of times that k-means algorithm
will be wrong with different centers as
the initial States the data result will
be the best output of n 8 consecutive
rounds in terms of evaluation metrics in
the caming class we can access the
matrix as an attribute which defines as
the sum of squared distance of samples
to the closest cluster Center this
matrix can be also used with grid search
to find the best and cluster parameters
the max iteration parameter defines a
maximum number of iterations of the
k-means algorithm for a single round as
we have shown before
Kimi's is an iterative method the center
will family converge to some final
position so the tolerance parameters
defines
how do we declare convergence based on
the difference between the matrix
between different iterations as euro we
define random States for the purpose for
reproducing the next step from the code
perspective is very straightforward it
has only wild line of code which will
help us to do monitoring in a prediction
at the same time it is just lace of
integers to represent which cluster each
sample belongs to cout
the final step is to plot the final
clustered prediction I'm not going to go
through the details of the code here but
I will provide a link to the full
notebook on our YouTube channel and
Instagram page family let's have a look
at the animation of the k-means
clustering algorithm start from
iteration 1 for this particular example
the model converge at around 7
interations
so this is a brief introduction of how
camis work if you found this video
interesting and want to learn more make
sure to comment like and subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]